derrière ses vitres à li na est en train
d'accoucher
une musique en fond pour éviter
d'entendre les bombardements la pièce
est très sombre des rideaux occultants
ont été installés pour éviter d'être
pris pour si
c'est un grand risque car le bloc à des
lumières trop forte et du cours et nous
pouvons être la cible des bombardements
finalement la nuit a été calme et la
jeune femme a pu regagner sa chambre
avec son bébé
c'est mentalement épuisant car vous vous
inquiétez à la fois pour vous et pour
votre bébé j'ai vu aux informations ce
qui s'était passé à la maternité de
marioupol
c'est surtout lorsque vous avez des
contractions mais que vous êtes obligés
de descendre constamment au sous sol
pour sauver votre peau et celle de votre
bébé
on est même pas sûr que cela serve à
quelque chose c'est car si nous sommes
touchés par un missile il ne restera
rien
une situation insoutenable pour ces
femmes enceintes qui à chaque fois que
les sirènes retentissent de jour comme
de nuit machinalement prennent le chemin
de la cage d'escalier et rejoignez deux
étages plus bas au sous-sol ce dortoir
installé dans la précipitation
aucune convention n'est respectée par
les russes alors évidemment on a peur
car on ne sait pas quelle sera la
prochaine à moscou
il y a tout juste une semaine une
maternité et un hôpital pédiatrique à
marioupol ont été bombardés
quatre personnes sont décédées et une
quinzaine a été blessé
sans prendre de façon délibérée à une
maternité est considéré comme un crime
de guerre